hi what's up gq i'm the kid leroy and
today i will be going undercover on the
internet
this is actually me
twitter
[Music]
how did kid leroy drop a song like
without you and then end up dating his
present girlfriend i mean have you seen
her yeah dude she's really really hot
yeah she's she's beautiful i love my
girlfriend when something's bad whether
it's relationship or like life stuff it
always feels like a lot so that's kind
of what inspires me to make songs like
without you and then i find someone like
my girlfriend shout out katarina and uh
yeah everything's good again
i absolutely love kid leroy but why the
does he add all his old songs to the
same album
ffffffff the reason i do that is because
so love i had all these songs that i had
recorded from that time period that like
i wanted to to put out but it didn't
really fit in the concept of like where
my album was going i just repackaged it
and added it on as like a sequel type of
thing so how about i just put it all out
and give it to you guys so i can be
clear-minded going into this next
project the kid leroy throws me off so
the kid leroy throws me off so much when
he talks because his accent sounds
really american to me but i'm not sure
if that's because i don't know that many
australians and my brain expects
everyone to be like another shrimp on
the barbie or if he really just talks
with a light american accent on my last
gq gq video funny enough i saw a lot of
those comments like a lot of the top
comments were like why does he kind of
sound american the answer for that would
be i don't know dude i've been in
america for like maybe a little over two
years now so maybe that's what it is i
guess i i haven't really been around a
lot of australians apart from my mom and
stuff when she moved out here it's weird
because americans will like tell me that
i sound super australian they're like oh
yeah i can hear it where are you from
like you from australia but then uh
australians be like man you [ __ ]
change dude
you sound american i'm like [ __ ]
read it
i never understood why people try to
call the royal pop artist where
literally 95 percent of his discography
is r b and hip-hop yeah first and
foremost i'm a rapper i'mma continue to
make rap and [ __ ] r b [ __ ] all the
people that
love it and keep checking it out then
that's for them and uh people who like
the other stuff got some stuff for that
too
but you know i don't i don't really like
look into the whole genre thing that
much i don't really like sit there and
make music and be like okay today i'm
making a rap song but today i'm making a
pop song i just kind of make whatever
feels good however you guys want to take
it you guys can take it why is blink 182
listed as right as a [ __ ] you goodbye
because [ __ ] you goodbye is actually a
sample of uh of all blank 182 song i
mean you gotta give the credit where
credit's due man
anyone know what the still chose you
music video is it's on the way and maybe
by the time you see this it might be out
maybe not though
so crazy how fast this dude shot up
heard he used to sneak into shows to
meet celebs and that's how he started
climbing wonder if he misses those days
in australia yeah i definitely miss that
[ __ ] man i miss just like running around
the city and like going on [ __ ]
adventures and exploring i miss like
that super super hungry feeling you know
i'm still like hungry but it's just in a
different way now i want to like want to
make the best music i've ever made
possible now i have like the platform to
like do that i definitely miss the
feeling of we have to do this we have to
do this yeah i definitely i definitely
miss it man for sure youtube youtube
that's how i always say youtube but you
americans say youtube
okay so this was this was a comment on
the without you video and it said i
wonder what the tick tock dance is gonna
be it it wasn't a dance it turns out
actually it was a uh it was a trend come
make a wife out of a whole thing and it
was like people just put like funny like
funny scenarios i don't know it was
funny though it was really funny that
stuff was really funny so um yeah shout
out to the to the tick tock people i
wonder if lebron is going to change his
name when he gets older no i think i
think i'm going to be the kid leroy
forever i definitely thought about it
but i guess everyone kind of knows me as
the kid leroy now so it'd be kind of
like dumb to just like change it up i
don't know it's kind of cool like kill
the roy like it reminds me of like you
know like like kid cudi like you know
like that's dope you know he's he's like
he's he's like grown now
uh this was on the not sober video it
said why the [ __ ] would you mix hennessy
with cola and my response is why the
[ __ ] would you know it this was on the
10 things that killed the royal without
gq video wow it's so crazy i look so
different in this video even changing
every day man shout out puberty gg said
thinking of getting more ice or what
what's your next piece uh i thought
about it for sure but about getting like
a cool little custom chain but like i
don't know again i'm not really like i i
feel like i'd get bored of it you know i
don't want i don't want to get something
and get bored of it and then like oh
[ __ ] now i'm like sixty thousand in the
lose that's some [ __ ] i don't even like
this was under the not sober video who
is stunner gambino how did y'all meet we
need more collabs with the both of you
guys stunner gambino is a
kid from new york who's really dope and
yeah i just i was just a really big fan
of his his music and his stuff and i
thought he sounded good on not sober so
i was like
slime
cora
what's your favorite song by the kid
leroy i don't know dude i don't really
have a favorite i don't really have a
favorite either stay or without you
which is kind of weird because they're
like my biggest songs but like i don't
know i i really like those ones okay
what did tick tock star addison ray say
to the kid leroy uh
what did she say to me
she was like hey dude this is really
cool thank you next
how did the killer roy rise up to fame
did his parents care about him rapping
and cursing my mom swears a lot
with her it's all about like respect and
like how you like treat others but like
in terms of the whole rapping thing she
was like yeah dude go crazy go after it
man if you want you can do it shout out
to my mom i love you
does the kid leroy write songs
specifically to be tick-tock heads no i
don't at all the only thing i've ever
done that with was the addison ray song
and that was only because i was being
funny and i thought it was hilarious but
uh i guess the world took that [ __ ]
super seriously which is you know i mean
it wasn't the worst thing that happened
and i also gained a new friend out of it
so
so yeah that was kind of cool
wikipedia from a young age howard's
mother who howard howard's mother would
play him music by the fuji's erica baru
and tupac
that is a fact my mom always used to
play that [ __ ] all around the house all
the time and another big one was kanye
next one is howard sees himself as an
ambassador for australia and wants to
show the world what australia has to
offer that's a fact in australia for
example when i was like coming up i
never really had um somebody that i
could look up to necessarily that had
like made it overseas and like and like
done it big for australia now me being
the person that's like over here and
like doing [ __ ] in america and stuff i
think it's very important to me for me
that when i go back i can help
kids out who are just like me i think
you know australia has some of the most
[ __ ] talented people in the world i
think the world needs to see that man
since moving to california howard style
has switched to high-end designers such
as saleem louis vuitton culinary garcons
and is known for his love of knitted
jumpers i am known for my love of
knitted jumpers i love knitted jumpers i
think they're [ __ ] sick yeah my style
has definitely
evolved but
you know my thing is like all matters
about what's in here man you as a person
as long as you as a person doesn't
change doesn't matter what the [ __ ]
you're good at man this is all a all
expression you know i think like close
is like another form of expression just
like music to me yeah i just do whatever
i want i just whatever the [ __ ] i want
so
this is tick-tock
[Music]
what do you do in your free time when
you're not making tick-tocks i actually
don't really make tick-tocks a lot so
i like record music i'll eat chocolate
chip cookies i'll eat pasta i'll eat a
lot of things in my free time i love
eating eating's cool i like going to
trampoline parks that's really cool
trampoline parks and like jet skiing and
[ __ ] this is instagram
arctic fire 301 says love the song but
the auto-tune why
when i perform live i like do a lot of
like jumping and like like running
around and [ __ ] you know i don't know it
honestly it just makes me feel a little
bit better about myself like performing
this one is by a casual magic and it
says hey charlton how tall are you you
look taller than justin and i am taller
than justin i'm six foot but with air
forces i'm one
yo what's it like having a number one
song it's sick dude i mean like
obviously it's crazy and uh i feel
really like blessed and grateful but
it's weird like i've said this a lot
about like other things but i'll say it
about this as well it's like you always
like have this expectation when
something like that happens you're gonna
like i don't know you're gonna like
unlock some like [ __ ] power and like
you're gonna feel like crazy like you're
gonna feel like have you guys ever seen
that meme of like spongebob like
floating up into the sky like that's
like like that's how you feel like
you're gonna feel so yeah dude i'm just
i'm just happy that i'm just happy that
people like it okay guys well that was
it my name's killer roy and uh this is
gq and uh i hope you guys had fun
listening to me answer your questions
have fun with your lives
[Music]